I like this new musician Billy Eilish
you guys like her she's this prodigy kid
can't just turn 18 she's incredible
she's too cool okay
neon hair green hair dress is cool speak
school I don't know about you but I
can't help compare my 17 year old self
to Billy and I get so frustrated like
ma'am Melissa you're such a dark it's
not fair Billy is so cool in interviews
this is how Billy Eilish talk she goes
yo I swear bro like my strange addiction
is I love tacos and burritos like I
swear bro like if you take me to a Taco
Bell right now
like I would eat all them in there like
I would have to take out my Invisalign
and eat all the burritos in there I
swear bro like I would die that's so
cool
what was I saying at 17 oh yeah I was on
AOL Instant Messenger messaging guys I
liked and every time they text me at MIT
with me and say sup Melissa I thought I
was hot by replying oh nothing just
chillaxing hanging chillaxing em and
Billy sings like wise beyond your years
beautiful smart beautiful lyrics you'll
sing like don't you know them no good
for you
I've learned to lose you can't afford
[Music]
[Applause]
the me at 17 I was singing this [ __ ] is
bananas
ba na na is gosh that song so smart
[Applause]